All right, have a nice pee.
All right, I have no idea.
Guys, if we... if we can get knocked out early, then we don't have... okay, I shouldn't say that.
Then we don't have to do day two.
And then all I'm saying is, one guy has to survive a hurricane, so...
One guy has to survive a hurricane, so...
Which guy has to survive a hurricane?
Okay, Raditz.
So, I don't know my sound guys in chat, but like, I don't have my... I don't have my...
I forgot to save my deadlock.
Deadlock sound settings.
Do you see what's happening?
What?
What's happening?
I'm going in and out of Ramblin.
Oh, I don't see that.
That's good.
Hello.
That's a good sign.
Why is that good?
Oh.
Okay.
The aura.
Disqualified.
Oh my gosh, I don't even know what I'm supposed to...
Okay.
Three, two, three, two, one.
Three, two, one, four.
Okay.
It's been a while since I've played A's!
We don't even have an Abrams on our team because they took Abrams from us.
I know.
Where the fuck...
Wait, where is Sage at?
He's not even in the voice.
I'm not sure.
Wait, is he like, there for real?
He's there.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, I'll be...
Wait.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, this must be EU favorite.
There's no way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hunter King.
Oh, okay.
It is King.
Yeah, because I was like, what the fuck?
How are they hitting that before me?
They're denying it really well.
All right, are these people EU?
Um, half of them are.
No, I know like the main...
The captain is, but I know like some of them are NA.
Oh my god.
Wait, this feels kind of impossible.
We're on EU ping, bro.
Yeah, we sure are.
Yeah.
I shot one bullet and I was like, that's not East Coast.
Okay.
That's fine.
We just use that as an excuse.
Yeah, yeah, that's our excuse.
Yeah, if we lose, that's because of our ping, right guys?
Yeah.
I'm just shooting in the general direction, hoping for the best.
I'll stride through my enemies.
I feel that.
I hope you're farming for me because... yeah.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Ray's a professional farmer.
Yeah, I hope you're farming.
I'm not... I'm not doing so hot, just saying.
We're getting them low.
Yeah, you just gotta fry them, Ray.
Bro, fuck you and your EU, like...
I mean, I got him low, I got him...
Oh my god, he's so low, he's so low.
I have to reload.
He's actually one.
I actually got him one.
Yeah, literally one crack.
He's got no swap.
I don't think I've secured a single one.
I secured one from their side.
Oh, nice, nice.
That's good.
Oh my god, he parried me.
How did he parry me in this...
Oh, never mind.
How did he parry me?
Oh, the kelvin's still there.
I can go bye-bye.
I'm gonna buy, actually.
Are you gonna be okay?
I hope you're gonna be okay, because I'm not looking at you.
That's a good teammate right there.
You just... you set him up for success.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just left.
I'm not gonna look, so whatever happens...
Yeah, I was gonna say, like...
All right.
Oh, okay, there you go.
I fucking finally denied them something.
Forgot what little ammo he has, too.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, you're so low.
Yeah, I'm gonna come back here.
I'll be back.
Fuck, okay.
No!
Why did you die?
Okay.
You went all the way back?
I'm so low.
For the moment you left, they fucking pushed.
They actually pushed the moment you fucking left.
You know what would be really funny?
Is if they're not EU.
Well, the captain is EU, so...
Yeah, I was gonna say, what if they're NA, and they're also playing on this one?
What the hell?
Why are we fighting an EU team?
They're like, these guys are lagging.
What part of...
Oh my god.
It was just, oh my god, I fucking unlocked the wrong thing.
It's a mess right now.
I'm too squishy.
Okay, I need you to tell me when I need to start farming, because I don't know.
Gotcha.
Seven minutes.
Seven minutes to camp spawn.
Yeah.
You want to get a bunch of 500 items, and then once you get Tesla bullets, that's when you can farm.
Okay.
Thank god I'm not solo laning.
Holy shit.
I'd be so sad.
Solo laning in this thing against Magenna is, you know...
Thank god that's not me.
That's all I'm saying.
Yeah, Abrams has got to be worse.
I feel bad for him.
I'm trying to press the parry button.
I just, I just can't.
It's like Street Fighter.
You gotta guess, right?
I'm just guessing.
Who's my tether?
I tethered one.
The one I casted.
Oh, I got ulted.
Goodbye.
I'm gonna watch you.
Pocket ultied me?
Oh, I'm trying to help you.
I'm assisting.
I somehow survived two ultimates.
Yep, I don't know how, but you're gaming.
Honestly, you're a gamer.
Wait, what the fuck is he doing over there?
Good luck gaming.
I'm really low.
I think we should just group back.
We have our zipline.
Yeah.
All right.
I've hidden successfully.
I've always known you can.
Do you have your boosting tin?
You're talking to me?
What the fuck is...
Oh, oh, okay.
The lane booster.
I was like...
You hit her with the boosting tin and broke the brain.
That was bad.
I mean, if you just said boosting, it would've been fine.
We added the extra words in there.
I think I may be in the statistical worst matchup.
You could've swapped.
Oh my god, I'm just getting obliterated.
Get down.
You could've swapped me.
My ping paradox against low ping Abrams.
Don't worry, my laner was sitting in the bush void, sitting with like five turrets.
And I was like, all right, well.
It is what it is, you know?
Actually, I think this isn't the worst matchup.
Yeah, I mean, this is like Shove's worst matchup, but I think...
I'm telling you.
You got your ultimate?
Yeah, I do.
All right, I'm gonna push.
No, Ramblin!
I'll get the one.
No, wait, what's happening?
What happened to you?
I thought their ultimate wasn't up again, but it was.
Oh my god.
I slept in though.
I was like, what?
I got him!
Nice, okay.
It's fine.
I just saw you insta-die.
Yeah, I got stunned.
Don't worry, we'll get our ultimate soon enough.
I was just like, why the fuck you just disappeared?
Okay, are you back?
Yeah, I'm back.
All right.
It's fine, we got our one fucking kill.
That's all that matters.
Oh hey, the farm's up.
It's time.
Goodbye.
It is time.
I believe in you.
I don't know how I'm going to...
Holy shit.
Wait, what the fuck?
How did it get worse?
The lag.
Oh no.
They're close by the way, so they might jump on you.
I know.
You know, the lag actually got worse.
How?
My lag was my... it was fine earlier until now.
Let me know if they push me.
I don't know, you want to look for something here?
Uh, sure.
I'm gonna have you guys stay on this side.
I'm also down to come.
Avery might be heading towards...
Our tower's going down in a second.
You have a good eye.
It's Jover for him.
I'm here to fight blue.
I tethered pocket.
Okay, I'm coming back.
No!
You were supposed to be the chosen one!
I got one.
I'm just getting refilted on cooldown.
Oh, pocket's still here.
Oh god.
On me, on me.
Holy shit.
I'm on my way.
Oh no.
I didn't know, I didn't know.
Oh god.
Life isn't beautiful after all!
No.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Everybody go Zippington.
Oh actually, wait, I'm gonna farm this real fast.
Yeah, Abrams is gonna be in our jungle.
I'm coming.
What the fuck?
Abrams, Abrams.
Oh my god, there's an Abrams here!
Alright guys, hey, um, I got Abrams.
I tethered him, I tethered him.
There's three in our green jungle, so...
Okay.
Guys, I wish...
I'm getting ultied!
Okay, I need to know who the fuck lag-switched the server.
Behind us?
Yeah.
Or...
Oh my god.
No, I don't.
I don't, I really don't.
He's so low that...
Oh, he's coming back.
Fucking, I'm trying!
Oh, who got ultied there?
Don't die.
Who hooked me?
If I can rotate to a green...
Yeah, they used Kalvindome.
Yeah.
I'm just getting giga-locked down!
Wait, you wanna swap with me, Gummi?
I can go yellow and hold if you wanna hold this walker.
Uh, sure, I can do that.
I got a Void.
There's a Kalvind here!
There's a Kalvind.
Oh, that's cool.
I got the swap.
I'm coming, I'm coming green!
Oh, nice shot!
Nice.
Where are you, Gummi?
Yeah.
Oh, that roll was...
Oh, don't die!
The fucking...
Die!
I don't think they're feeding, people.
Oh, they got it!
I don't think they're here, though.
I'm gonna try and get something to farm.
I need to farm so bad.
Okay, maybe we can take this tower, question mark?
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm farming.
The Abrams is purple and I don't think anybody else is killing it, probably, unless they send, like, four.
Oh my god.
I'm having a...
This game looks so weird when you're lagging, I never realized.
Nice.
She ulted.
I have barrier for you.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Yeah, I can tank.
I can tank her.
Oh, it was red, but it's okay.
Oh, there's someone on you!
Who's you?
You need to be...
I am you, I'm you.
You need to be very specific.
I'm coming, guys.
Yeah, I'm going for this.
I see dynamite.
I'm not late.
We're not on, uh, purple.
Where did I go?
I'm just a little guy.
Pockets by me.
They might come down here with me.
I'm heading over.
Oh, are we coming to blue?
Yeah, they wasted wraith ult on me.
They're downstairs with me.
I'm heading over.
I'm coming.
I'm pocking them up.
There's three in here.
We're here.
There's four, I think.
I can't tell.
There seems to be a lot of people.
Don't go in.
There's a dynamo.
He's waiting.
They're half.
They're all half.
They're healing now.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I'm like...
Oh my god.
There's a dynamo.
Okay.
Oh my god.
The fucking sound.
I'm dead.
I believe in you guys.
Okay, I stopped believing.
Oh, I got that.
We got Abrams, though.
That's a big chunk of money.
There were so many people there.
That was a moral victory.
It's okay.
I'll get your land.
Yeah, I don't want to deal with that.
We blame ping.
We blame...
Just be like...
Three blue, four blue, four blue, ping a walker.
Just a heads up for everyone.
Bravoss.
I'm coming.
I'm coming blue.
Coming back to blue as well.
I think I can tether one.
I tethered pocket.
Oh, I might try to get a swap.
It's not your fault, ping.
They're rotating out.
Might go green.
Blame the ping.
Just remember.
It's not us.
It's the game.
I'm going purple.
Abrams is going green.
I'll come from the beginning.
Abrams going there too.
Whoa.
I might just fucking wait until I get...
Oh, I'm a cube.
What the fuck is going on?
Abrams here.
Abrams is here.
Good fight.
Keep going.
There's only one left.
Get him.
Oh, pocket.
We're in Z.
I see him.
Oh my god.
He's fucking running like a little bitch.
I know.
We're okay.
Fuck your shit.
Oh my god.
I've played EU servers, but I've never had this lag before.
So it's so weird.
Oh my god, guys.
Where does she come from?
Okay.
Oh, I can get this now.
What is it?
What's my next one?
Five.
One.
There's three here.
I'm trying to get a swap green.
Oh, turn around.
Don't worry.
I distracted them with my feet.
Love that.
Keep doing that.
I believe.
Distracting them with your feet.
First Jerry, then Vindicta, huh?
All right.
How is he chasing you?
There's an Abram here.
Yeah.
Are you okay over there?
I like to believe I'm okay.
Oh, all right.
I'm still...
I'm watching this.
I'm gonna clear yellow, and then I can come over.
I wish I could farm.
You can go farm purple side, maybe.
Are you guys okay if I leave you guys to farm?
Are you guys okay with that?
I haven't...
I've been getting cyberbullied so I couldn't farm.
Nice.
Three more here.
We have two executes, but I think we can handle Abram.
That's good.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe this is too strong for me.
No, we're fine.
Yellow's shoved also, by the way.
If they stay here, we might be good.
Wait, you guys want to fight?
Will you guys be okay?
Down.
Moving up.
I'm coming.
Oh, Abram's right.
Oh, Dynamo has ult, though.
One of them's in the mid-boss.
Top mid-boss.
Yeah, we should...
I'm swapping one.
I don't think we need to fight.
I'm going to go blue.
Maybe I'll go blue with you going to the tower.
Yeah.
Also, the buffs are up.
Say less!
Oh, Wraith's next to me.
Two green.
You okay, boy?
I'm good.
I'm tempted to just fucking farm for Ricochet right now.
Do it, do it, do it.
Oh, there's a big squad pulling up on us.
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna fucking farm just for Ricochet.
Wait, TP'd out?
No.
Oh, you should get Tesla bullet first, though.
Makes the farming juicier.
How much is Tesla bullets?
3,000.
3,000?
Okay, I'm gonna go for Ricochet first, because...
Oh, you should.
You should go with that purple wave.
Just because...
Actually, what?
Go to the purple.
Go purple.
Go purple instead of the jungle.
Well, actually, let me explain it in a better...
Oh, I'm dead.
I was too busy.
I was too busy looking up on that.
There's an Abrams coming over.
The minions in the lane are worth more than the jungle camp.
The minions are worth more than the jungle camp.
You should always try to get the minions in the lane.
I'm trying to swap in the Guinness if I can.
I have...
I'm so close to getting a...
Getting Ricochet.
Yeah, also, you don't want the building to die.
I think they just want to save the tower very desperately.
Can someone save our blue guardian?
Yeah, I'm good.
Okay.
And then, when I'm up, I'll come green.
I'm so close to it.
They might send it on purple.
Oh, yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
There's a...
There's three.
There's three people on me.
There's an Abraham all the way back here.
Oh, my god.
Abraham.
That was unintentional!
Swapping him back.
I'm so mad.
Run!
He wasn't even doing that intentionally.
Oh, no.
Pocket top.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
That's actually so unlucky.
How did I lose my money?
What?
Oh, yeah.
You lose your farm from jungle camps if you die without spending it.
There's three on me.
I can pull.
Really?
I'm on my way.
How did you know that?
I used Wraith ult.
I'm good.
I'm coming blue.
Are we able to fight this or no?
After I heal, I'm going to get Wraith ulted.
They're backing up.
Oh, my god.
That's so unlucky for me.
I literally lost all my farm from jungle.
Abrams is tethered, but...
I'm here.
I'm on Abrams.
I'm going to grab Tesla now since I have it.
Wraith exited green side.
It's not in my thing.
Tesla.
Tesla bullets are here.
I can't believe it.
Ugh, that farm I did.
Oh, Abrams on me.
I'm coming.
That's like the most unlucky thing that happened to me.
No, I'm dumped out.
There's a pocket behind also.
I'm on the pocket.
Oh, I got ulted out.
That's unlucky.
Plumbing Abrams away.
I'm dead to pocket here.
Do you need help?
Do you need...
I know.
I'm Wraith ulted.
Magical Leap these nuts.
You sicko.
I'm heading over.
Buck is going under towards mid.
I see him.
He's over here.
I don't want to be here.
Oh, I don't want to be here either.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Okay, goodbye.
Someone just hit my head.
Oh my god, I'm yellow.
There's like four on Ramblin.
Oh my god, please.
I'm leaving.
I farmed some stuff.
I need to go.
I...
I'm so scared of losing my farm after that one time.
Play it safe.
I guess...
They're trying to get the green walker.
Oh, they are?
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Holy shit.
Okay.
This is tethered.
Mechanics is low.
Heading over.
There's like two behind us.
Wait, we can...
We can kill this.
Oh my god.
I'm here.
Oh, she has so much healing in this pit.
Oh my...
Oh no.
You don't sound very happy right now.
Nah, that walker is just dead, I think, sadly.
I'm here on Abrams.
Swapping him back.
Oh, there's a wraith behind you.
Oh, I couldn't...
I didn't get the sleep.
Oh, he ulted, you guys.
Yeah.
Anima's one.
Nice.
Oh, I got...
It's okay.
Like, I got hooked.
I got hooked.
I'm okay.
Weak minds can never catch me.
Guys, life isn't beautiful after all.
Holy shit, he heals.
I mean...
We really need a flex.
Oh, wait.
Oh my goodness.
Surely, it's killable.
Okay.
I always believed in you, Gumi.
Wait, maybe life is beautiful.
I really need to go.
Maybe we can turn this around right here, right now.
I'm gonna turn my monitor on.
I've been playing with my monitor off.
Glasses are on.
I'm moving to EU so I can play with this ping.
I'm applying for citizenship.
I'm applying for asylum so I can...
I'm applying for asylum right now.
Right, this is coming over to you guys.
She's invading.
I'm afflicted.
Oh, I'm dying in the altar.
Oh shit, do you guys need help?
I fucking left second.
They spent like three alts, four alts.
I don't think there's any help in that one.
They spent four alts.
Oh my god, I'm almost...
Guys, I really need like just a tiny bit more farm and then I can have Ricochet.
I am so close.
I really need like four alts.
Please.
They're still chasing you, Ramblin.
Please, where is the four?
Here.
Ramblin's Cuber.
There's an Abrams right there.
Are you okay?
Ramblin has been vibing.
Kelvin's one.
I'm cubing.
Okay.
All right guys, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving because I need...
There's that one last farm right there.
It's awesome.
It's literally right there.
I need four.
Can we contest or not?
I'll try.
Ramblin has nothing as well.
I'm also gonna try to steal.
Doki has altski.
If Doki comes out.
Yeah, I'm coming.
I can.
I can come.
I'm going for it.
I'll try to sneak Doki and then...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have no...
They have no dynamo.
I can go in first.
I am very far, so give me a sec.
I'm walled out.
Fuck, I was just too early.
I'm so close.
Meme on my way.
Wait, you guys...
Are you guys...
Oh.
I think we should go home.
We should turtle.
Guys, I got ricochet.
It's over.
I can actually contribute.
Oh, yeah.
I can finally do something.
Her power spike.
I'm dead.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
Guys, it's okay.
I have ricochet.
It's okay.
Did you apply for citizenship yet?
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I got one...
Step one done.
Step one is over.
Oh, it's over for them.
Oh.
By the way, I got chased.
You're their own people.
Why would they do that?
I was trying to apply for citizenship.
Why would they do that to me?
You're doing it right now.
I don't like those liking you.
Me too.
I would like...
Yeah, maybe we could all...
Can we like...
Maybe if we pause the game for like seven hours and then we all like...
Get on a flight.
Get the closest European country and then just land there.
British.
We get on British Airway.
British Airway.
Go to London and then all of us land there and then unpause the game and then we win.
We catch up with 50 points.
Yeah, I'm down.
That's...
It'll be just...
It's just that easy, right?
I'm down.
I mean, this sounds like a plan of attack.
Yeah, yeah.
Honestly, I feel...
Someone was like, but Britain's not EU.
They're not in the European Union.
True, that's true.
What the fuck?
It's a sleep.
Tether, tether, tether, tether.
Guys, I need help with a fucking...
There's two people on me.
They're not on you, they're on our base.
Oh, okay.
But I'm in the base, so technically they're on me.
I think the patron might be American.
Yes, he's North American.
Our fucking patron's a traitor.
Come on, dude.
Okay, so our issue was that we didn't have a single European player.
I think that was our problem.
I did not.
How do you know a bunch of European people?
All right, okay.
Maybe, like, we can grab a European people in person and just be like, can we pause so we can swap?
Can we pause so we can, like, there's something wrong with our accounts and then...
Wait, was the server...
Did we pick the server or...
No, they said they were going to pick a server that's, like, the closest to all of us.
But it's clearly not.
There's no way this is the closest server, because I play with Europeans.
And I've never lagged this badly before.
Yeah.
Hey.
You live and you learn.
Yeah, we live and we learn.
Not bad, not bad.
We should be, like...
Oh, it's... Yeah, it's auto select region.
What region are we in?
What's our region?
Didn't we have played US East to even it out between EU and anyone on, like, West Coast?
I just... Yeah, it should be, like, on the left side, right?
I mean, it should be London, right?
Oh, no.
I've never played in London.
Bro, I...
There's no London.
I played...
I played League.
What server did they play?
What was... No, there's England.
Was it England?
We should have just picked, like, South Africa.
What if we were in Finland?
Wait, we're all lagging.
I played...
I... Okay, I don't even know.
Wait, I'm gonna mess it up.
We've been okay in Finland.
Oh, my God.
That was actually...
Hey, Doki, complain!
Complain!
Oh, no, they're saying sorry.
Apparently, they're, like...
Sorry, we did...
They actually apologized.
They're, like, sorry, we...
For the lag.
And then, apparently, we've been running it on...
And apparently, our game was the worst the lag has ever been.
That's crazy.
It's a good vibe, you know?
Our game was the worst the lag has ever been.
It is what it is.
Do we play next, or do we go to the winners?
So, it's first to one.
Little European situation.
Oh, our next match is against Americans.
Our next match is against Americans.
It's over.
It's win-win, it's over.
I kind of liked the European ping, though.
No, you did not.
You were, like, Stockholm Syndrome'd yourself, dude.
That very felt good.
There was only three players that had sub 100 ping.
There was...
Those three players had to be on the other team, because it wasn't us.
I think they were three, America, three of you.
I think I got reyfelted six times.
Bro, I was, like, stuttering so hard.
Like, my frame...
Like, my guy was, like, fucking five frames per second because of the lag.
If we were European, this could have never happened.
That's so true.
We should have...
Oh, my God.
We knew we would...
Both all of us would have just left NA yesterday.
Yeah, we would have just moved to Europe.
Wait, I got the plant yesterday.
At a business expense.
Okay, before our next game, we all order some fish and chips.
Yeah, just...
No, we're playing against Americans.
We're playing...
We're playing against Americans.
I didn't know that it's gonna...
You deserve it.
I'm eating a jacket potato with some beans.
I can't believe it.
I couldn't even use my...
I don't even use my...
A jacket potato?
With some baked beans and tuna.
Tuna?
Yeah, some tuna.
Beans are fire.
You know, guys, I was like literally in a meeting.
Yeah?
What's up?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So you had your own AI play?
Bro, I was farming against McGuinness.
And I was like, wow, this is really laggy.
And mid-meeting, I'm like, yeah.
So, you know, the thing about that is we can just look to do some, you know, we can...
I thought you were trolling when you said that yesterday.
No, I literally had a meeting at 12.
I was...
I told Gumi, I was like, I'll be in a meeting.
Yeah.
He's in a meeting for the first 15 minutes of laning.
I'm like, if you don't get the TPS reports, the viewership analysis of that, I'm just like getting punched to death by McGuinness.
I was like...
But I don't...
Who had to lane against Abrams?
I'm sorry for you.
Sorry, Void.
Void.
I think maybe for our next draft, we should draft Abrams and Shiv first.
I think they had first pick.
They knew.
You can't tell me they didn't know.
They picked Abrams.
Yeah, I got the plan.
I got the plan.
We first ban Kelvin, first pick Abrams.
No, we...
No, how about we just ban Abrams in general and nobody can have it?
I don't know.
We have three Abrams players though.
Yeah.
Yeah, to make it fair, you ban it so none of you can play.
And then nobody can be happy.
Well, if it's on NA ping, I don't...
It's NA ping, by the way.
Yeah, next team is versus Americans.
I wanted to know what my ping...
What do you guys think about the Kelvin ban?
Frick that guy.
I...
I don't know what you can ban.
I don't know what's a good ban character.
I don't think any of us play him.
Yeah.
I got a Kelvin game in.
I lost.
Oh.
Okay, well then, yeah.
Yeah, let's make sure to ban it.
Sounds good.
That's toxic.
Hold on, I'm reading the learn to play section real quick.
Okay.
I'm learning to play, I'm learning to play.
I'm doing the four minute get started tutorial.
Oh, true.
I'm putting up Kelvin in the sandbox.
Breakdown of the tutorials.
I have the eight minute lane training incompleted.
What does that even mean?
We can even...
Oh,
apparently my stream died.
How the frick did my stream die?
It died multiple times, apparently.
Me?
What the frick?
How?
Oh, did the pain really?
My PC was like, I gotta connect to Europe.
It sounds like that.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
The Europeans took down a PC.
I have a question.
Yes.
The very first Slam Doki, you had like a new PC that was unset up in your...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was me.
Are you still using it?
Yeah, no, I'm using the new PC.
Okay, okay.
I was like, ugh, I was sitting there the whole time.
I used it since the last Slam.
Okay, all right.
That's why when you spectated my game, it didn't look dog shit.
You know what's funny?
Like, as a professional, when I watch and the match is in fucking slow motion, you just ignore it and you're like, wow, nice, nice punish there with the...
It's just normal for me at that point.
Everybody complained about...
You were EU in that tournament.
It was like the first three seconds.
It's only the first three seconds.
Watching you get coached and the game just freezes and Brawl Pro is like, Doki, what's going on over there?
Hey, it worked out in the end.
Are we like right after or like, are they playing another game before us?
I don't know.
I'm doing the training segment.
I don't even remember how the schedule goes.
Like if there's a gap in between.
Chat, is there a gap in between or are we up next?
Yeah, chat, you tell us.
Yeah, you tell us.
We just went through some fucking trauma right now.
Yeah, chat will know.
We're not fighting the EU demons like the...
Guys, I need to know what words they're ping.
I need to know what they're ping was.
Everyone talks to him now.
Tell us where they live.
I think our match is supposed to be 1.45-ish PST.
1.45?
What?
Maybe like another...
Are they going to play the other one first?
Wait, how?
Okay, I'll be like, can we play...
Wait, our match is in 40 minutes?
I have to go.
They were in 3-ping.
The AV team was on 3-ms.
World boss, world boss, 7 minutes.
When is our next match?
Because I'll go.
I have to go.
I think it's 30 to 45 minutes from now.
We can't play with team Doki if Doki leaves.
It's going to be team Doki in parentheses.
No bird.
I'm not there.
I'm like the...
I'm like the org leader.
You know, the org leader.
I'm the org.
That's you.
That's me.
Wait, if we have that long, we could definitely move.
Yeah, I was going to say, can we have our next...
Our match up...
Match next, if possible.
No, I meant to Europe, but...
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Europe, yeah.
Why don't we just move to Europe?
Oh, true.
Yeah, what if we didn't consider moving them to North America?
That's...
Yeah, why can't they move?
No, because the tournament's hosted in London.
They can come too.
Oh, yeah, true.
And SageM's going to pay for it, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, we can slam.
Let's make it happen.
Let's make Deadlock slam.
Brick it.
You know, running tournaments costs a lot of money.
Get all the fighting game players to play Deadlock.
Well, you just have to win the tournament and you get money back.
Oh, true.
Oh, that's true, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, does this tournament even have a prize?
No, it's for charity.
We were complaining for charity.
Yeah, who was complaining about paying?
It was for the kids.
How could you?
You know what's funny about that?
It's like whenever I work a charity event, I literally don't look at the talking points and I just say, for the kids, guys.
Like, that's like, I just...
I'm like, guys, it's for the kids.
We're the children, guys.
They're very important.
All right, let's see.
Okay, yeah.
It's literally in...
Oh, yeah.
It's gonna be a while.
It's at 45 minutes.
Oh, okay.
He has to literally go at two.
Yeah.
Yeah, I have to get subbed out.
Can we hire our own sub?
I'm sure if we're in here.
Oh, my God, I forgot.
I literally looked up fish and chips.
I can't believe...
I guess we got an excavator.
I mean, I'm down for sure.
What happens if we get a sub and then we qualify for tomorrow?
We do day two.
And by the way, I didn't think we're gonna...
Guys, we're not gonna qualify.
It's at six in the morning tomorrow.
It's at six in the morning?
I'm learning so much about this tournament as it goes.
Like, there's so many things I didn't know.
I didn't know either.
Because I didn't say anything because I knew we're not gonna get day two after that.
Guys, I decided to omit that information because I felt like there was no possibility that we were gonna get to day two.
What kind of belief is this?
What do you mean?
I'm about to lock in.
Hold on.
We're not gonna be locked in.
We're gonna be fighting other European teams.
I'm missing the frame.
If we win against the NA team, we have to play that European team again.
Oh, then it's over for them.
I'm moving to EU.
I'm locking in.
It's done.
Like, I'm about to...
Hold on.
I'm about to learn Swedish.
Like, I'm about to beat their ass.
Hold on.
They're speaking English.
What are you...
They're gonna need a translator if they want to talk to me.
I'm about to lock in.
Hold on.
I'm about to be European.
Can't fucking immigrate right now just for deadlock.
Oh my god.
It's all right, guys.
For that one game, we put...
I can't believe we have to wait 45 minutes.
Yeah.
What are we gonna do?
I mean, I can play...
Let's pick it up again.
All right.
I can play like...
Okay, if they don't start at exactly...
If they start like late, then I definitely can't do it.
But like, if they start early, I can do the second match.
What do you have to go do?
I have another stream scheduled.
I had a collab.
Oh no.
I had like two...
Do they play deadlock?
Exactly.
Maybe they can sub in.
I don't think they can sub in here.
Okay, let's just...
Should we just six-stack right now and see what...
Play the game as it's intended?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
We might as well play the game as it was intended.
Wait, I haven't seen...
Do we even have time though?
What if our game goes long?
Fucking do you really think?
What if one of them gets stomped?
What if they have like a 10-minute game?
Then we'll just leave.
I'm pretty sure we can't get...
Oh, true.
You're right.
There's no rank yet.
We could just leave.
Oh, right.
You would leave a game in progress?
Yes.
You would leave...
You've seen me in SageAnne's Lab.
If Doki dodges...
You would dodge a game in progress?
That's true.
Only Doki if he dodges and the rest of us can legally leave.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If Doki dodges, it's good for the rest of us.
Yeah, I dodge because I'll just be like, get the sub in.
By the way, you guys should find a backup sub right now.
The idea of leaving a game in progress to me is like...
That's against the rules.
You can't do that.
It's not in the terms of service.
Oh.
Do you know that for sure?
I don't know.
You're gonna fact check me?
Go fucking read the terms of service.
All right, hold on.
In section 1.8, zombies are from the top.
We got time.
All right.
Okay, who's making the lobby?
I'm in Goomy's Lobby.
You'll queue without me and Ray.
We're on third limited.
What do you mean queue without you?
Ray is deafened.
He's locked in.
What is happening to this team?
You guys are doing an MMO boss?
I got someone leaving at 2 p.m.
I need to play a real game, guys.
Oh, now you want to win.
No, I just want to know what it's like to play a real game.
You know, we all played together last night.
Yeah, and I was busy last night.
Okay, I need to know what it's like to play a real game, guys.
Come on.
How many MMOs have you played?
Huh?
How many games have you played?
Oh, that's a good question.
Let's see how many hours I have.
Like...
I have...
Okay, to be fair, I had the game open too sometimes.
So I had the game opened for 17 hours, but I know for sure I didn't play 17 hours of games.
I think I've had maybe like at least 10 games.
All right.
That's pretty good.
I think it's pretty good.
Are you seeing my stats?
Wait, Gumi, are we...
Gumi, invite me.
Invite me to your group.
You're not even online!
Yes, I am!
Oh, not like...
You're not online on Steam!
Oh, you can send our code, yeah.
Yeah, you can send...
Yeah, the code.
Send me the code.
Copy party code.
Okay, let me make sure I don't show the code to people.
All right.
Oh.
One, two, three, four, five.
I'm in.
Our party contains a wide skill range of players.
Toki must be really good.
Yeah, I'm too high.
We skewed our MMR.
I'm too high for you guys.
Yeah, so that's...
You might make us fight two tough opponents.
Oh, no.
Are we getting Ramblin and Ray in here?
I'd love to.
Right, guys?
Right, Ramblin?
Ramblin?
I mean, I can join, but you think that a team of mine will be paused for five minutes?
Come on, get in here.
I want to know what it's like to play a real game.
I can't believe they're world bossing.
I'm hopping on.
Wait, did somebody actually have three ping?
Yes.
Name them.
That's what I get to like the US, the California Valorant server.
That's why I was so surprised that the auto select favored that, favored one region, because only three of them had 3ms.
While, like, overall, it should be like...
It should have found the middle.
Ramblin, type him in.
Liberty, throw my...
Oh.
Ray, can you hear us?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You joining us?
For what?
Is the game starting?
Yeah, the game is starting.
Turn the game right now.
Go, come on.
Is it actually a turn a game or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Our game just got up.
Yeah, you have...
They decided to move our game up.
Oh, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Sorry, I'm just trying to kill this world boss real quick.
Sorry, we'll just auto it to death.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
No, I'm starting to feel bad.
Why is no one else cracking?
What do you mean?
Why are you feeling bad?
Don't be nervous.
Yeah, don't be nervous.
We're playing N18 this time.
So what's the code?
What's the code?
Yeah.
This one, put it in the join party portion.
I'm in.
Okay, lock in your character.
I want to play an experience with their Abramad.
It just sounds so awesome.
Are their Abramad three ping?
Yeah, but I'm fighting against somebody who has 150 ping.
You want to fight somebody who has 100 ping?
Like, dude, my heavy melees would go in.
You know what's fun?
Like, okay, so the fighting game player in me was like, oh, it's laggy.
I should just punch them.
And they immediately parried me.
And I was like, what's happening here?
And I was like, what's going on?
I was like, what is this?
Like that's, you know, when it's laggy and fighting games, you, you abuse the lag tactic.
There's so many things for you to be cheesy in fighting games with lag.
So I was like, oh, I'll just abuse the lag tactics.
And I punched and I was like, oh, my bad.
They parried me so fast.
They were gaming.
I'm pretty sure like they could see you like 100 frames ahead.
Like at that point, like you were just slow motion parrying.
Yeah.
I was like, oh, there's no way they're going to be ready.
I mean, people on North American ping don't like parry that fast.
Then like, you know, the first time you punch them, I was like, all right.
I think they just see you and it's like slow-mo for them.
Oh, true.
I wonder if that was what it was like.
Because I was definitely like my, my, my character was not okay.
She was not, she did not feel okay.
It's crazy.
Oh, so my chat was like, I made it.
Did they win?
Assimilation.
We won so hard.
We became European.
Oh, my God.
Wait, are queues really that long?
Yeah, your skill level is too high.
Oh, my God.
Wait, really?
Oh, I knew it.
I knew I was better than all of them.
You knew it was a skill issue.
Yeah, yeah.
I think it's because our party has a wide skill range of players.
So it's just trying to find someone who's as powerful as us.
Oh, I thought like, I thought Deadlock just goes with the highest MMR.
It just goes with that because they don't balance.
I thought they don't balance MMR.
Individual lanes against each other.
I actually think they're trying to put us in an EU server.
Transferring us to EU right now.
I actually don't know if you noticed this, Void, but I noticed in matches now where I have this logo, it tends to put the highest MMR player in a duo with the lowest MMR in your group.
Have you seen that?
I don't know.
I saw that a couple of times recently.
What usually happens for me is one of my solo lanes wants to swap.
So I swap and then I kill them early and the guy I swapped with explodes.
Yeah, yeah.
You guys both agreed to smurf is what happened.
You sacrificed your teammates.
He sacrificed himself.
Smurfing is illegal.
As a boy scout, I would never leave a game in progress or smurf.
Nerd.
What?
Huh?
I didn't hear you.
I was just checking.
Maybe we should get on another account.
Wait, you have other accounts?
I do have another account that I have easy access to.
Well, we did have this.
We had this logo before, so it might not matter.
Wait, are you trying to say you're gonna smurf?
No, I would never.
Well, mama don't know won't hurt her.
Who's mama?
Who's that?
Oh yeah, who decided that Gumi was our coach?
Oh, true, true.
That is true.
What coach don't know.
Bro, did you guys hear that this hurricane is so powerful that it's like picking up fire?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You're gonna die to Milton.
Oh, we're not dying.
You're gonna survive through Milton.
Why did you say that?
That's crazy.
What the flip?
Oh my god.
One bad Geist game.
Yeah, you play one game with a hard lane.
What?
One game, hard lane, 150 ping.
I said in Minecraft.
You know what?
Tonight, I'm just opening my door.
I'm running in that.
Yeah, just get out there.
Go scrap.
The thing is, like, now, if you die, we get to laugh about it.
Like, it'll be...
No, I'd be...
I would be crushed.
But I will make fun of Doki for a long time.
I'd be like, why did you do that to him?
Why did you give the prophecy to him?
This European hurricane pulled up and pulled him out of his house on 150 MS.
You just sentence him to death.
That's why we have 150 MS.
The 5G towers are getting taken.
It was all for charity.
Wait, yes, I'm linked to the charity.
I forgot to ping it.
I forgot to pin it in my chat.
Yes, I will link to it.
Oh, none of you guys linked to charity.
That's...
Wait, what is...
I was in a meeting.
What am I supposed to put?
Oh, okay.
Guys, here's the...
I'll add it.
What is it?
Yeah, I'll put the code.
For the kids.
There we go.
Yeah, I wrote for the kids.
I mean, him dying for charity would blow up the charity.
And then people would start donating.
Harsh words, I don't know if you are correct.
What are you saying?
This bird.
Calm down.
For the kids, for the kids, for the kids.
Every time Ray dies, we donate one dollar.
Deadlock, of course, right?
For the kids, guys.
It's for the kids.
I'm like Kenny from South Park or something.
One, one...
Okay, how many times have you died for the last game?
I mean, we should...
I died like 10 times.
10 times, so that's like $100.
Oh, I thought we were doing times 10.
That's crazy.
You might as well donate a little more if it's for the children, right?
You said blow up the charity, too.
That's a crazy thing to say.
Why did you say it like that?
Because it'll go viral.
Because we'd be like, during the hurricane, this man played for the Deadlock tournament.
Even though he was going through one of the biggest hurricanes in America right now.
And here's the charity link.
It went viral.
It was.
When I said I was a Boy Scout, I could be outside doing cocaine and I'd be way less...
I'd be way less evil than what's happening here, I bet.
You have an evil choice already.
I could just be on the corner selling drugs and I'd be like, I'm the morally outstanding one.
I am a good person.
I'm literally in a charity tournament.
That just absolves me from all evil.
I'm just like outside selling a bunch of high schoolers fentanyl and I'm like, I'm the good guy on this team.
No, not yet.
Not yet because you haven't started yet.
Oh, okay.
Remember guys, shout outs to Milton, you know?
Yeah, shout outs to Milton.
Milton, man of storm.
Oh.
Imagine.
You guys get that reference?
Yeah, yeah, I got peer pressured.
I wanted to be just as cool.
Wow, right?
Wrong.
Millhouse, man of storm.
Guys, Ray's gonna die.
You gotta laugh at his jokes.
Oh, that's why when you said that reference, we all pretended to know what he was saying to make him feel better.
Yeah, you know what?
I'm jumping in this hurricane.
Wait, before you jump, can you like...
Before you jump, can you link the charity?
I'm taking down my shutters.
I'm just gonna open my fucking window.
No, no, no, can you link the charity before you jump?
I'll record a video.
You'll record a video?
I'm gonna make a video where I say Doki's my 13th reason why in the majority of the world.
Has it happened?
Ray, that's just a $5 dono.
Thank you, Ray.
$5, big fan of Ray.
Wish, guys, we should all donate to charity in the name of...
Does it have a message?
Oh, it doesn't have...
Guys, guys, someone should donate in the name for...
As a memorial to Raytus.
I think everyone should donate in the name of Raytus.
Yeah, yeah, if you're gonna donate to charity, just be like...
Rest in peace, Raytus.
Don't say that.
Doki, no!
Doki, Doki!
I'm in Minecraft, in Minecraft.
There's so many times you can pull that out.
You can't just end Minecraft your way through life, okay?
You can't just like...
You're at a job interview, you're like...
What makes you a bad candidate?
I do drugs in Minecraft.
Like, you can't just like...
End Minecraft your way through life, like...
Jeez.
Oh, man.
It's okay, it's okay, guys.
We've been in queue for like 15 minutes.
How?
Oh my god.
This queue is the longest I've seen, I think.
This is the longest I've been in, I think.
I thought this queue was popular.
What's going on?
But I swear...
Maybe it's bugged, maybe it's bugged.
Wait, it can get bugged?
I can split it real quick.
Because the other turning game is at the 10 minute mark.
And then Void Dodge is for us.
It doesn't look like it's going to last long.
No, I can...
Yeah, that's true.
Wait.
It's not a beatdown, but it...
It looks like it's about to escalate.
Okay.
That's even down five minutes.
Yeah.
All right.
What's the plan?
Guys, who needs a warm-up?
When you're just such a solid Splatoon like us.
Like, look at us go.
I mean, we already warmed up because we're at 150 ping.
So we're like Rock Lee taking off the weights.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Guys, I think I barely played the game during that last game.
So I think I...
I think I need a little bit of warm-up.
All right, me, you, and...
Wait, why don't we just go into...
Why don't we drop in an apex?
Let's go into sandbox mode and just practice on each other.
Oh, true.
Sandbox?
The sandbox?
Let's get Void back in here.
Void, get back in.
The game is actually starting for real now.
I'm almost there.
There's the code.
Did you just have him do 1v1s in a lane?
Wait, but then that's not fair to the person I'm laning against.
Because I'm too good.
I just got absolutely plucked.
Unknown joined.
Who's that?
Oh, yeah, that's my new name.
Gulp?
Is it actually?
That's the real Voidlock.
He's so powerful, my Steam can't figure out his name.
It's Voidlock.
You not like Bluelock?
I love Bluelock.
I do too.
Let's go.
Oh, that's your dog, by the way, guys.
I think your dog did something.
Do we even have enough time to play an actual game?
Not really.
No, I don't think so.
That's why we're laning.
Okay, I'll DC all my Smurfs and then we can all DC.
Oh, the game went a lot more easy.
We have time.
Okie, lock in.
Wait, I have to lock in?
Okay, I locked in.
Okay, I'll give it five minutes.
Five minutes?
I need to eat a Tums.
Wait, we're back in a queue?
Yeah.
What happened to Sandbox?
Do we want a Sandbox?
I thought we were doing a...
Oh, it's fine.
Can we set the Sandbox so you're...
I don't even care.
She's actually serious about this.
All right.
Look at us.
Look at our squad.
Oh my god, look at us.
I'm buying everything right now.
All right, we'll ping a Rion.
I'm changing teams.
Wait, why?
This is what they felt like?
Holy...
This must be nice.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was gonna...
Or let's practice killing these minions for 30 minutes.
When I was doing killing minions, I was like, how are they denying me of that?
That's so cute.
Don't ult me, please.
Don't ult me.
I'm too hot and sexy.
What the fuck?
Yo!
Okay, where's my lane partner?
Wait, am I solo lane?
Wait, who bought items?
What, you didn't?
I thought we were warming up at level 1 first.
This is level 1.
You don't see a magic carpet Viscous level 1?
Bro, I saw a magic carpet Viscous and that's all I know.
I hate the Marauder Beetles sound effect.
Oh, that's...
No, don't do this.
Oh wait, no.
Give us flux slots.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna...
I'm grabbing.
I'm gonna grab that item.
I'm gonna...
I'm buying.
I'm fucking buying.
Get your ass back here.
What?
Unstoppable.
Where are you?
No.
Oh, you guys aren't ready.
You're fucking cheating.
You're such a whore.
I was like, Ray's doing a lot of damage.
He left clicked me for 300 damage.
Who the fuck put this at 0 cooldown?
Who put this at 0 cooldown?
How is this actual practice?
There I was in lane, level 1, farming.
Like a hardworking individual.
And this guy's magic carpet goofballing.
Oh my god.
What if I can't...
If I can't beat them?
That's right, I'm coming for you.
I'm fucking coming for you.
Who uses this item?
Who actually uses magic carpet?
Look at Ramblin.
I'm fucking burning.
What is going on?
No magic carpet for you.
No.
No, I'm just kidding.
Leave me alone.
That's looking great.
Infinite cooldown Naga.
Bro, there's a DBZ battle in the air.
What the fuck is happening?
Sparking Zero just came out.
This is insane.
What the hell is going on?
Oh my god, get me out of here.
I picked someone who sits on the floor like an idiot.
Like what am I doing?
Clearly doing the wrong thing.
Guys, this is exactly how our tournament match is going to go.
I'm taking this building to the next game.
You're taking magic carpet?
Yeah, magic carpet.
I mean, magic carpet, Viscous is real.
It's factual meta.
People want to nerf it.
It's way too good right now.
You might as well just play Viscous just for magic carpet.
You might as well all get knocked down too, just in case.
We all just buy knockdown just in case.
That's fucking right.
I'm giving you practice.
What do I look like?
I'm stealthed on the carpet.
You're stealthed?
Wait, where are you?
I'm going to go find you.
I guess it doesn't unstealth.
Curse?
You bought curse?
Okay, wait.
Oh!
What the fuck are you?
You're a monster.
That's fucked.
I had to send a message.
What do you want from me?
I'm fucking gonna hide.
If nobody can see where I am, I'll...
This guy Ramblin's having the time of his fucking life up there, I can tell.
That's it.
Why do you think that's it?
Unstoppable.
Oh, she's...
She's like infinitely...
big chillin'.
That's it.
Easiest game of my life.
I will go on forever.
Yay!
I wonder what this looks like.
Is this just a carpet flying around?
I don't even see you.
They took out Bebop.
Oh, shit.
No, not Bebop.
Anyone but him.
Oh my god, he's just a silly little guy.
Bro, what the fuck?
Oh my god, there's a hazel.
He's bouncing off his building.
I think we're ready for you.
I think we're so ready.
We're so ready.
I don't think they can take us.
I think like, after that training arc of 150...
I'm pretty sure I was 200 MS.
Because I'm on West Coast.
So like, I'm pretty sure I had...
I'm also West Coast.
West Coast.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure I was 200.
Because I know I'm 200 in Apex.
Gumi, I swear to fucking god.
I will...
I will make sure we get to Day 2.
If you do...
Southern California to EU is pretty far.
That's the worst thing you've said today.
Yeah, that is crazy.
When you said you wish Rey died, I thought that was less offensive.
If you keep doing that, I'll make sure we make it to Day 2.
I swear to fucking god.
So, my chat was asking about it, but if people missed it, their team was half EU, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Half.
And then the other half was not, but we played on EU servers where we had like 160 ping.
Yeah, but the other three were with 3 MS.
3 ping.
But they had like...
Apparently our match was the worst the ping has ever been.
I mean, I believe that.
Oh my god.
All I'm saying is that...
Shout out to the guys.
Shout out to everybody for donating to the charity.
Guys, because...
Look in chat.
Yeah, look in chat, guys.
And for Rey.
It's for Rey and the kids.
In that order.
Kids first.
Oh my god.
You guys are gonna laugh, but wait until he's mid-game and his power goes out and he just disconnects and you never hear from him again.
That's my boy right there.
And you're wishing ill will on him?
That's crazy.
You are very specific about that, Seija.
You are so specific.
Are you trying to...
What are you trying to say?
What's gonna happen?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna plug right now.
I'm plugging right now.
I'm gonna plug.
Dude, that's throw loops.
That's three-potter right there.
I'm safe.
No one will know where I am.
No one will know where I am because I have to tab out and send a message.
Gumi Gumi flew right at you.
Please, I need to type a message.
Gumi, I swear to god.
I think the bot is gonna start punching you.
I'm trying to type a message.
Is it for charity?
Yeah, it's for charity.
Of course, everything I do is for charity.
Well...
Well, what?
I'm watching Voi get his 50 reps of Riju punching in.
What is Bebop doing here?
Well, you know.
I gotta make sure I can punch it.
How do you check for ping anyway?
Oh, 13ms.
Oh,
27ms.
There we go.
Wait, somebody should check what their ping was last match.
Can we though?
I know for sure I had 150.
Wait, no, Seija, you should check because you're closest.
Wait, you're also SoCal, right?
Yeah, I'm OC.
Yeah, so I must have 150 also.
Oh, I'm in Canada, so RNG is not the best.
Well, also, you're further north.
Yeah, I'm further, too.
I'm further in.
I covered it.
I fucked it.
Shite.
Alright.
I need to send my message.
Oh, okay.
By the way, this is our draft link, by the way.
Huh?
We could probably do it sooner than later, right?
The donation's insane.
You just saw it?
I didn't even see it.
I thought we were just trolling.
That's insane.
It's for the kids.
See, Joe?
I'm a big charity event fan.
I'm with it.
Are we drafted?
They're 40k down.
Hey, just like us.
I was gonna say it, but then I stopped myself.
Wait, what did he do?
They're down 40k.
Oh, shit!
Let's go!
Wait, who's they?
The team that we lost against?
Oh, I forgot.
One of these teams are the teams we lost against.
Yeah, yeah.
Are they the team that...
Imagine they went against a better EU team.
No.
Who's winning?
What if they're actually beasts on 100 ping?
Which one?
The NA team?
No, the three ping guys.
What if they're like, oh, this is weird.
I'm literally...
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Oh, no.
The AU team is beating the other team that they're playing against.
Are they also American?
I'm gonna look up the fucking Wikipedia right now.
It says that's country flags next to...
Okay.
Oh, they are EU?
No, they are EU.
So they can't even blame ping.
It's like their own skill diff.
Maybe they're on American ping now.
They have the country flags.
The country flags.
That's next to their names.
One is from UK and one is from Poland and then the others don't have the flags but I assume they're also EU.
So we had excuses.
True.
So if we win this next game, how many more games do we play today?
And then it'll be immediately the last game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So at most, two more games.
This is feeling like a TFT, Tony, with the time in between games, bro.
I never played TFT so I don't know that reference.
Oh.
Yeah, no one plays TFT, right?
Yeah, yeah.
My bad, my bad.
You gotta be more with the times.
It's not a TFT anymore.
It's like Among Us.
There's like a giant emergency meeting in between the games.
Oh, that's...
No, that's still not relevant.
It's like...
It's lockdown protocol now.
Lockdown protocol.
It's lockdown protocol and we all gathered around in the main lobby.
Yeah.
Can't even relate.
An unrelatable streamer.
Who can relate?
Very usual.
Alright, let's see.
New message.
Alright.
I love that Rae just gets called old in cold blood.
What are you doing to them, Ramblin?
I'm rescuing them.
Rae looked at the donation.
Oh yeah, I saw that.
RIP Raeditz, your flip into the hurricane was epic.
I'm literally doing tricks on it.
Right now.
You brought your setup outside.
It's like he's in the rain.
Doing a McTwist.
He's like, what a...
McTwist.
What is a McTwist?
You gotta do the McTwist over the helicopter.
When Rae died like 10 times, he was in the center of that hurricane right there.
Isn't the eye the worst place to be?
No, it's the best place to be.
It's the best place to be because it's where nothing happens in the center.
Not really though, because it's going to move and then you're going to be in the...
You have to continuously move with the eye.
Because I don't know if you guys know this, but hurricanes move a lot.
No, as a Californian, this is the most foreign concept to me of all time.
If the ground starts shaking, I got you covered.
Oh my god, so much chat was like, wow, natural PC cooling?
Wow.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, you got that PC cooling in the hurricane.
You got the water cooling.
I hate water cooling.
I don't know if anybody else hates water cooling.
That shit always explodes on me.
I'm a hater.
You just stick a big ass fan in there.
Like the radiator always dies or like...
I don't think that's supposed to happen.
I don't think that's common.
Do you just use water cooling or do you do lava cooling as well to make obsidian?
Lava cooling?
I gotta get in on that one.
Lava cooling sounds like...
I gotta get in on that.
Oh, I saw like a PC where you can get Mountain Dew cooling.
Can I ban McGuinness?
Oh, we're banning?
We're picking a banner?
Yeah, what do we not play?
I can ban McGuinness.
Do you want me to...
I can request an A server and be like...
What specific server do we want to play on?
Sounds like most of you guys are west.
Just put England.
I ban McGuinness already.
We should play...
We should get Abrams for Doki.
Do we get two picks?
I don't know.
Can we get Viscous so I can play anything else?
We can go Abrams, Viscous.
I literally just learned Haze.
Oh my god, time to go back to Abrams.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go.
Abrams, buy the magic carpet.
What does that even look like?
Wait.
For Abrams.
I don't know if I meant like for Abrams.
Oh my god, imagine Abrams up in the sky and then he does the number four.
Bro, that shit would be sick.
The number four.
I think there used to be even a melee on the carpet.
Wait, can you still do it?
I don't think so.
That was a Yamato build.
Yeah, I can't do it.
Whenever I try it, I fall off.
So you just do like drive-by backstops.
So like, okay, get over here, Mirage.
We're going to have a magic carpet fight.
What are we locking now?
I think I void pocket now.
Okay, pocket.
Pocket.
You can last pick it.
Probably, they won't take it.
Okay, what about you?
I can play...
Infernus, Shiv.
They won't play Infernus.
I can play Shiv or...
I'm thinking who's good for our team here.
Wait, what server are we requesting to?
Like, specific server.
What are our options?
I don't know.
I'm assuming there's West, Central, and East.
So we want Shiv then?
I'll just lock in Shiv.
We want West, Coast, Central, or East.
Five of us are West Coast.
Me and Ray are both East Coast.
Can we request West Coast server?
And if anything, East Coast server.
Central.
We deserve to know what it feels like.
Bebop!
No way.
They bebop this?
They're playing bebop?
Oh no.
That's Yuumi's enemy.
I want Bibimbap now.
Yeah, give me Talon.
Okay, this is what we've locked in.
You know what?
I'm happy as long as we don't go against McGuinness.
True.
I'm happy because you guys can finally parry.
Guys,
don't do that to me.
Sorry.
I just did it subconsciously.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
I guess I also have to use the bathroom.
I'm going to pee in Void's bathroom.
Hey guys, I'm going to be here.
Oh, me too.
I actually don't need to go.
Oh, okay.
I just wanted to be included.
Are you going to be included in the bathroom?
Yeah.
In the bathroom party?
And then leave our chat alone?
Empty?
With no entertainment?
Because I was going to say, people in other people's chats, I'd never leave you guys to go to the bathroom.
That's what I was going to say.
I would like to co-sign that I would also never leave.
Yeah, so like, we care.
That's the difference.
My stream chat...
My chat, all they talk about is that your laugh makes them laugh.
Oh shit, really?
Guys, instead of listening second hand at Sejam's stream, you can head over on YouTube and check me out.
It's Doki Bird.
But if you guys want to listen to a second hand to my chat, you can head over to Sejam's stream, which is on Twitch.
And that's why I can co-sign that Doki is awesome.
Yeah, see?
But you can leave everybody else.
If you're in all the other people's chats who left you for the bathroom, you should come to our streams, because we wouldn't leave you.
Hey, Goomy.
What happened?
I was peeing.
Oh, there was nothing.
We just left.
Yeah.
I have a wireless headphone.
Yeah, same.
What did we say?
We were talking.
If anyone wants to listen to me not second hand, hop over on YouTube.
And I was like, no, also hop over to Sejam's stream and everybody else who's playing in this tournament.
I wouldn't leave you guys alone, chat.
I wouldn't go pee.
She said she'd sell your body for drugs.
I'd take my chat to the bathroom with me.
Wait, you took your chat?
Wait, you actually talked to your chat while you were in your bathroom?
No, I have a camera and everything, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Are you lying?
No, I have a GoPro on mine.
Isn't that bannable?
Where is the GoPro on?
Yeah, where is it on?
Also, isn't that a bannable offense on Twitch?
Wasn't there like a really tall guy who did that?
Yeah, wasn't there one guy that did that once where they went to a bathroom and got banned?
Didn't that happen before?
Oh, like streaming in the bathroom, right?
Yeah.
I think that guy's also a doctor.
Oh, he's a doctor?
He has an MD?
An MD, yeah.
I was at TwitchCon this year and I was wearing a microphone and I took it off and I was like, we don't want any recording in the bathroom, right guys?
And Twitch did not laugh.
At least we can laugh with you.
They didn't laugh, you just see them look down and write something on a piece of paper.
Guys, when there's no slam at next year's TwitchCon, we know why.
We know why they did it.
So here's the code, guys.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
We're not showing it on stream, right, everybody?
No, of course not.
You guys would never do that?
No, that's why I'm the first one in here.
Well, I didn't want to leave all of you because, you know.
Why are they all Warden?
What?
It's like a puzzle.
Who do I join with?
Uh, Ducky's Abrams.
Wait, why are they all Warden?
That's terrifying.
I'm scared.
Why are they so coordinated?
Wait, two of them are connected.
It's like the hat and the body.
Do you see that?
In order.
Oh my god.
Oh, they're trying to do it in order, so it...
I'm messing it up, I'm messing it up.
Yeah, you guys were being coordinated.
You're in the bottom.
Yeah, look at that.
Yeah, that's icky, right?
You guys were trying to be coordinated.
Wait, let them do it and I give you the feet.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we need him to move up and go, Ray, go!
Yeah!
Wait, that is sick.
You have the feet at the bottom.
Look at this guy's mustache over here, pissed.
He's so mad he can't get up.
Bro, they were practicing their whole...
Yeah, so much that they were practicing their whole lives for this moment and we ruined it in one second.
They couldn't even get it going.
Okay, what lane am I going?
Am I staying back in green?
I don't know.
I'm chill with whatever.
Do you want to send...
Do you want to play in a lane that's not a side lane board?
Um...
Low-key, yeah, but I'm also chill with a side lane too.
What's happening?
If I'm in one of the other lanes, I do like roaming a lot.
Yeah, I was going to say, you have a little bit more agency if you're not in a side lane.
Yeah.
I can lane with Doki.
Alright.
I need somebody to babysit me.
I got you.
Great Talon solo lane.
Alright.
I like how they were like, Hey guys.
Two moustaches.
Yeah, they look a little...
Wait, let them choose their characters first.
Oh, well they know what I'm doing now.
Well...
Sorry guys.
I sort of messed up a little.
Wait, none of them even picked Warden.
Yeah, they're wild picks.
That's literally the only profile picture they had.
You guys are disgusting.
So we're against Infernus Wraith.
Bebop is next to us.
Yeah, but we can always...
Do we have to go to these lanes?
We can swap lanes right now.
Well, we can also swap in game now.
Yeah, that's true.
That is true.
Dynamo hate.
Their solo lanes are really strong.
I don't know, Ray, because you...
I was going to say, I don't know how you do against Mo and Krill.
But Bebop is probably worse for you, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I feel like I could do decently against Mo.
Are we happy about these formations, everyone?
Do we want to swap anything around?
Do we care?
The only thing I was going to say is, do we want to send Pocket or Viscous into the solo lane against Bebop?
I love fighting Bebop.
Okay, we can swap Sage and Min.
I think that's a good idea.
Okay, I'm just going to ready up here, and then we're going to swap in game.
All right.
They won't expect it.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're not going to have our streams turn up to see what we're talking about.
A charity tournament?
Yeah, a charity for the kids?
Are they really going to sabotage the children for the sake of winning?
That's true.
Anyway, so whose streams do you guys have open?
We just open up all those streams.
Yeah, we just open all the streams right now while we're talking about it.
I'm watching Warden's mustache.
Okay, so like the Haze, right?
They're just saying that the Haze is going to start flanking the blue lane.
I'm actually a three-year sub to Warden's hat.
Oh, shit!
I bet you're not even a tier 3 sub.
You got me.
I knew it.
Because I'm the tier 3 sub, and I never saw you there.
I'm only a tier 2.
Is there a tier 3 club?
I didn't know.
Damn.
Yeah, I'm in a tier 3 club.
That's fucking right.
Damn.
Yeah, you fake fan.
Have you guys ever tier 3 subbed anybody?
Nope.
I've never even tier 2 subbed anyone.
I'm a tier 3 sub to Rambo.
I think I tier 3 subbed once.
One whole time.
I did it once, but it was for feet pics.
I don't think that counts.
Are we good to start the match?
I assume we are.
Whose pics were they?
Guys, I'll be honest.
I don't know what server we're on, but I chose West.
It looks like West.
I clicked in West.
It's over.
Oh my god.
It's fucking over.
Alright.
Okay, Blaine and...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm not going in and out of Ramblin.
My character is okay.
Wait, no way.
Ramblin said good luck.
Good luck.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, they didn't swap.
Oh my god.
I can actually...
I can actually hit the orbs.
That's crazy.
Holy shit.
I've never...
I can actually deny them.
Oh my god.
What is this beautiful landscape I've encountered?
This is so crazy.
I don't know how to feel about it.
Yeah, now that I have EU citizenship.
I don't know what to tell them.
Now that we're EU gamers.
I'm going to buy real fast.
Me too.
Now that we speak their language.
I know.
Now that Sejuan learned fucking Swedish.
Like, what the fuck is he going to do now?
Yeah, what are they going to do about me now?
Yeah.
After he burned his American passport.
Like, point.
Literally never even heard of America.
What's with these Americans?
They call their leagues the world championships.
And only Americans can play in it.
You know what I'm saying, guys?
That's true.
Now I sound like a real fucking European.
What the fuck is American football?
You don't even use your legs.
NA.
NA play.
Land of the free.
Am I right, guys?
Oh, I'm going to get punched.
Oh my god.
It's so weird being able to deny.
I feel like we're in a hyperbolic time.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
I'm not used to it at all.
Oh my god.
I feel like I should be culling my tether.
I'm going to pull up on him.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
That's got a little bit of damage.
Oh my god.
I mean, you have so much regen.
But I'm having to poke a little bit.
It's just Mo and Krill.
What are they going to do?
Buy Shadow Weave?
What the fuck is Shadow Weave?
I got him.
Bye.
I need to upgrade.
Okay.
Alright, I'm back.
Oh, okay.
My bad, my bad.
Oh, he's in here doing the farm.
Oh, he is?
I'm coming over.
Oh, he left.
Okay, right idea though.
Yep.
I'm coming back to you.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh, goodbye.
He's low though.
He's one.
Nice.
She's one too.
I got her.
I'm fucking backing out.
Oh my god, this is what it's like to play the game at an actual level.
I'm buying.
I'm going to buy.
Yeah, I'm going to shove this in.
I believe in you.
I kill our camps.
It's brutal out there, huh?
I'll come by.
He's going green.
I'm here now.
We can back it up then.
Okay.
Let me shop real quick.
I don't know.
What are you going to do?
Kill us?
I'm staying.
I'm tethered.
Whoa.
Here.
Yeah.
Work on tower.
We have ult first too, I'm going to get a little...
Oh!
Big man's on top.
Oh, he's so low!
Yeah.
Furnace is one.
Yeah, I'm going to push up his end.
Moe's going green again.
Goodbye, goodbye.
They're both low.
Oh, they are?
Oh, I went back because you said...
Me and Ramblin do get confused for each other a lot.
We're literally the same person, so like, undetainable.
I'm here.
I'm here with you.
They might collapse on you also, right?
I'm gonna come to green.
I have ult now.
I'm ulting green.
Bird coming in green.
Yeah, we can fight off this.
I'm coming over here.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Oh, I can't.
I have the turret on me.
He's just backing.
Oh, he was behind us?
Wow.
Yeah.
I didn't see him.
My bad.
We have a lot of money, too.
Wait, what the fuck?
I dived him?
Oh, nice.
That's huge.
No, he's dead.
Oh, nice.
I dived him back.
Oh, they blackballed.
No, goodbye.
I can fight him while you run.
I'll try.
I got out, I got out.
Haze is at the end of the tower.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm chilling.
I'm okay.
Excuse me, I'm going to be behind the blue lane.
Oh, one and then five.
I might need to go back for heals.
I'm going to go back.
Can you come in green to poke them a little bit?
Yay!
I'm behind them.
Right there is exactly one HP.
Yeah, I just helped poke a little bit.
You guys are.
I'm coming back now.
Furnace backed.
I'm here.
Creeps responding.
I'm going to go steal.
Hello, everybody.
Abrams is here.
Welcome.
I'm coming to green.
Yeah, I'll pull up.
I have rage now.
And Furnace is in my lane now.
I'm on dynamo.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where did he go?
He was in the sky doing his thing.
I lost track of him.
I may have trolled.
I might need a little bit of help.
Okay, I'm on my way.
I'm going to just take their farm.
I'm going to go shop.
I'll go get the yellow farm.
Me too.
I need to shop too.
I'm here.
I'm going to be farming yellow as well.
I'm just going back.
They left.
I saw Inferno zipping away.
Do we help the other lanes or what?
Yeah, I'm just shoving this in.
Let's do it real quick and then dip in.
You can just farm all our jungle in their camps too.
Alright, yeah.
I farm.
Farm time.
The waves are always the most money.
So anytime you can catch a wave, you should do that.
And then in between, get the camps.
Sweet, I'm learning.
We love that.
On top of my head?
We love learning.
Not really, but like...
I'm trying my best.
I like just reinforcing it and just...
Oh, Bebop's over here.
Grab that green wave.
I got a reload.
Moe is here too.
I'm with you.
I'm coming back.
Disarmed?
Oh, nice.
Exploded.
I'm coming over.
There's more farm here.
There's one here.
I'm going yellow.
He's bald.
Oh, hey.
Are you guys okay over there?
Need help?
I stunned him.
I'm heading over.
I think Haze is coming over too.
Oh, there's Moe too.
We can dive.
I'm on my way.
Haze ulted.
I'm gonna burn.
Haze ult canceled.
I need help though.
Nice burn!
Please stop!
Bro!
Like, stop!
Yeah, we can just back it up.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh, I got hooked.
There's like three people there.
You're so dead.
Okay, they used like every ult.
Okay, I'm fucking backing out for it.
Nice, we can just go farm and take the buffs.
They used Inferno's Dynamo, Haze, and Mooncrawl.
Okay, I'm backing out of green.
Yeah.
I'm gonna farm here a little.
Oh, I don't care if it's on me.
I can hold green.
Yeah, we can fight for this, Aaron.
Okay, I'll be here.
Dynamo.
I'm gonna come over purple, man.
Mommy, wait.
I don't know why I tried to hook you.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Yeah, we can...
Or walkers have.
You wanna push that wave out there?
Wanna push where?
Push that green wave.
Okay, yeah.
I'm gonna push the yellow while you guys are doing Aaron.
Oh, they got the Aaron.
There's a lot here.
I'm coming over to you guys.
We should be able to win this.
Yeah, I'm heading over.
Dynamo's in blue.
Nice.
I see...
Dynamo's coming over now.
I'm on the Wraith.
Pyro's in front of me.
I'm getting Wraith ulted.
Pyro's behind you guys.
Dynamo's behind you guys.
You got him?
We should...
Can we mid boss?
Oh, sure.
I'm crushing the walker.
We have a bird.
I'm starting it.
Never calm.
I don't think we can.
Yeah, it's probably not.
Yeah, I'm backing up.
You're too far away from it.
Yeah, we can just take their farm.
Push in on the walkers.
Yippee!
Wait, I want to push this farm.
I want to push blue farm.
Can we kill them again and then the boss is a little weak for us?
We can stop them.
They're shooting me.
Push mode activate.
I'm going on Dynamo.
I'm going to grab this farm real quick.
He's just hiding there.
There's a Haze in blue.
There's a Moe and Haze.
Oh, they're all there.
They're all in blue.
I saw three on blue.
Blue tower.
I'm a bird.
Yeah, it's way too late.
Oh, you are by yourself.
I'm so dead.
Yeah, I'm like watching this.
I can try to deny their farm.
They burned three ults.
Yeah, yeah.
They burned Bebop ult.
They burned four ults.
Holy shit, just for you?
What did you do to them?
What did you do?
I just existed.
They don't like Europeans.
They don't like that you betrayed America.
There's a Moe coming to you.
There's two coming to you in green.
I'm chilling.
I'm going to go purple.
It looks like they're collapsing on green.
Yeah, they are.
I backed up.
Moe's up here with me.
They were so mad that you betrayed America.
From just one game.
I can push green whenever.
I'm waiting.
Oh, I'm in trouble.
I'm with you.
Oh, I am in trouble.
Oh, you are.
I'm trying to help you.
Wait, nevermind.
They slept in Wraith ulting me.
I'm pretty sure I get purple walker here.
Yeah, you can probably get up.
There's a Moe here in front of me.
Yep.
There's three.
There's four.
Yeah, you got the walker then.
I'm going blue.
I don't know where to go.
You can just stay far instead.
Just look for the green triangles.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
There's a Haze on Wraith.
I'm going to steal their shot.
I'll get you on Wraith.
They can probably push the blue walker.
I'm already on it.
Hello.
We're here.
We're here to help.
I'm afraid of the five ult burn here.
Nice, we got the walker.
Buffed her up.
There's a B-Bomb coming over.
I'm going to steal your fucking farm.
Oh, I shouldn't.
They're coming over.
They might be collapsing on you.
I'm sorry.
It was a joke.
It was a prank, bro.
It was a prank.
Me to try and steal it.
You did not have to be splitting farm with me.
We got the Urn.
Okay.
They want our purple Guardian also.
There's an Infernus on me.
Okay, I'm heading over.
I'm going to support Urn.
Infernus ulted me.
I should be okay.
I'm heading over to you guys.
I got Haze and Mooncrawl.
There's a Wraith here too.
We should go check out the Urn.
I don't know where the Dynamo went.
I'm heading to the area now.
Just in case.
They have no Hazel and no Mooncrawl.
They're both purple.
I'm heading over.
There's a Void coming.
We can get the Urn.
We can turn it in.
When I'm up, I can go purple or blue.
Monocle is right there.
Might be looking to fight for no reason.
That's fine.
I can clear purple.
And then probably blue.
I'm just going to grab this real fast.
Heading over to you guys.
I'm coming over green then.
I'm here in green too.
Are we pushing up?
Void is just killing everyone.
That's what's happening.
Oh, nice.
Cool.
Do we have time to do mid-boss?
I think I'm going to push.
Infernus is on green.
I don't know where to go.
We're on mid-boss right now.
I'm here to help.
Dynamo is far on yellow.
Infernus is not close either.
I'm pushing out a little bit.
I'll parry.
I'm going to fly and look around.
Nice.
Yes sir!
What do I upgrade next?
I'll probably just shove some waves here.
I found Link can fly some more stuff.
Oh, there's a mowing curl in green.
In this line, bro.
Oh, Infernus is in green.
In this line.
I'm here.
If you want to get crazy.
I'm here too.
I'm down to get some freaky right now.
You guys want to get freaky?
Yeah, I'm fucking ready.
Wraith is coming over from blue.
They clicked all of the ultimates.
They clicked everything.
I stunned everybody, by the way.
There's no way I lived through this, right?
Oh my god.
Okay, we did it.
What the fuck happened?
I don't even know what the fuck happened there.
Holy shit, we actually did get freaky.
I'm in with you.
Hello, thank you.
I can tether.
I don't know.
Nice.
Getting freaky right now.
Wow, I was wondering where the Wraith was.
Oh yeah, freaky time!
Oh, thank god this was a 20 game.
Yeah, what about the next game though?
Oh, no.
What?
Alright, the Patron.
Oh yeah, you're gonna go inside?
The streamer is awesome.
Oh my goodness.
The Patron's up right now.
I'm getting moaned for ulting me!
Oh shit, hey.
Bro, what am I looking at?
You don't know how to parry.
Wait, I just realized these players don't know how to parry.
Nice.
Oh my god, this is what it would've been.
Yeah, this is it.
Nice.
We did it!
Yippee!
Oh my god.
Yay!
What?
Wait, is it like straight after?
Apparently, yeah.
Straight after?
Okay, wait, if it's immediately, okay.
Okay.
Is the game...
If it's immediately, okay, let me see.
I might be 30 minutes late.
We made it.
I'm mid-tournament.
We made it too far in the tournament.
It's for charity and for the kids.
Oh my god, they're watching the stream.
Yes, ASAP.
Okay, here's the...
Here it is.
The...
The thing, okay.
We gotta do this instant.
Alright.
It's for the kids.
We are doing it for them.
Alright, who are we banning?
For the kids.
Are we banning children?
Are we?
No, no.
The team that beat the shit out of us.
Advanced.
Let's go!
I like that, I like that.
Wait, are we down to ban McGuinness?
I mean, do we need to?
Do we need to?
Do they play McGuinness?
We can literally check their bots.
Cory, someone check the bots right now!
Okay, wait, chat, chat!
The team we're playing.
Aqua.
Did they ban...
Do they have McGuinness?
I like this.
This is our strat.
Chat, who should we draft?
Hurry up.
Chat, please.
For the kids.
We just need to know if, you know...
Wait, we haven't read it up yet, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're scouting us out.
They don't know what we play.
We play everything.
Don't worry, I'll unready.
My chat was telling me they're calling us by our in-game name.
So, like, yo, Jam Jimadome.
Jam Jimadome!
With the pic!
Owner of the Jam's El Jimadome.
That's him.
So, I was like, are you asking us to stream snipe for the kids?
Well, this is a charity.
The kids would be down.
You know what?
The kids would absolutely love that.
Kids love stream sniping.
It's their favorite hobby.
Who's banning?
They're EU!
But we can ask for the most...
We can ask for...
Yeah, an East Coast server.
We could be like, can we have East Coast?
So it's in the middle between all of us.
They should just put a server in the middle of the ocean.
You want me to ban?
Are we all in agreement with banning Kelvin?
Sure.
They banned Pocket.
Wow.
Haters.
Pocket?
Pocket is his second best character.
It's true.
That's not even his first pick.
Should I pick Hayes?
Probably Abrams.
Oh, they're picking Abrams already.
No!
I need to pick Hayes.
Why are they always first picking?
And then I'm locking in Peridot.
How did they always first pick every time?
You should pick Viscous.
He saw me hover.
He's only a Viscous player.
He's a demon on the goo man.
He saw me hover.
There's like a puffer fish in his helmet.
Yeah, Viscous is like goo from the sea.
Also, I gave you guys the new code, by the way.
Oh, there's a new code?
Is that the lore?
Yeah, that's the lore.
They chose Vindicta?!
It's okay, I play V-Buff.
Can we just like forfeit right now?
Okay, it's our turn, right?
So, we want...
Oh no, it's Talon's turn.
I could play Paradox, but I think I might want to play Warden.
You want Warden instead?
Pick me...
I don't mind having the choice right now.
So we can pick other people.
Pick me Lash.
You want Lash?
Yeah, frick it.
Don't you also play Wraith?
Yeah, but...
Yeah, my mouse is bugging out when I hold left click.
Did I give the wrong...
I feel like Lash is an insane pick after they do Vindicta greats.
Yeah, Lash is a good choice.
I also play Lash if you want to pick something else.
If you want to play Lash, we can do that, sure.
Actually, because I think...
Well, let's see what they pick.
They picked Dynamo.
It's our turn.
How the frick did they always first pick?
Yeah.
I'm also down to play Infernus.
Infernus, I'm down.
I'm down to lock in Infernus.
We know they're EU.
They are EU.
We can try and ask for an ESCO server.
Can we get an ESCO server?
As a fellow European, I think a US West server...
Yeah, yeah.
It's only fair for the kids.
We're literally here for the children.
Oh, look at that.
For the children.
They care about the kids.
I mean, that's where the majority of the children are, right?
Yeah.
Most people do live on the East Coast.
Sure, sure.
We combine the majority of the children on the East Coast.
I'm pretty sure that's more than London, right?
It might be.
Our team is like, kind of tanky.
I like our team.
I'm down for Bbop or McGuinness.
I have two open slots.
I'm down for the McGuinness.
Okay.
I mean, Bbop into the Flyers is...
Are you a hook god?
I don't know if I'm a hook god.
I'm a bomb god.
Hook god, on the other hand.
Okay, I'm a beam god.
It must be a beam god.
Beam god.
We want Bbop?
Bbop?
I don't know what I want.
I'm easily swayed.
I need to be told.
I don't know.
I'm playing this the 11th time I've played the game.
I believe in the Bbop.
Bbop.
Flawless draft.
We're tanky.
They can't kill us.
They can't kill us now.
You can't milk those.
What?
I want Arlene.
Where are the other teams?
I'm down for wherever.
Where's the other team?
Oh, there they are.
I'm just happy we're on East Coast.
Who finishes as well with Bbop?
I don't know if I want a solo lane, per se.
Who's going to play in my lane?
I'm going to be Haze.
Oh wait, if they're watching my stream...
I'm going to be...
Infernus.
You're going to be Warden.
Yeah, I'm going to be Warden.
What are the other characters in this game?
What are you guys going to do?
I prefer not solo laning.
Not much.
I have no prep.
Guys, the kids are depending on us.
Guys.
The kids are depending on us.
If we lose...
We will disappoint the NA children.
What do you guys want?
As long as I don't fight Wraith, I think I'm good.
I can stick with Gumi.
You want to solo, Warden, or do you want me to go?
I can go solo.
If Wraith's in blue.
Vindicta is on green lane.
Do you want to go, Gumi?
No, I'm just saying it.
If that matters.
I don't want Gumi against Warden.
Yeah.
Me and Gumi can swap.
Watch out, Void.
You're against moron ultimate.
I don't want to lane with Doki.
What's that supposed to mean?
I'm an ultimate player.
I don't really know how to farm that well.
All I know is bomb.
And Doki.
And I don't know anything.
It's like putting two dweebs together.
In a locker.
So maybe Doki swapped me?
Two dweebs in one locker.
I mean, I've jumped into a couple lockers in my life.
Oh my god, are you okay?
Because you had no friends back then.
That was reflex, I'm sorry.
Okay, Doki, do you know how to swap?
Yeah, just walk over to blue.
Well, you get off the rope early.
And then you tether to blue.
Okay.
What's going on here, guys?
I feel like Doki has said evil things to me all day long.
It's too easy.
I'm sorry.
He just puts it out there.
I appreciate you being there.
Well, Doki, your mom puts it out there.
At least I have a mom.
What?
Who is that talking about?
Doki, look at your character!
The time is now.
Aqua hasn't even locked the character!
And not even the last person!
I think Aqua is great.
Aqua locked it earlier.
Guys, I think we could go pro in this game with this team.
I think we got it.
This is the squad, right?
Not even the last person who didn't lock the character.
It's not even my fault.
They did lock in earlier is the thing.
If this guy doesn't lock in, I'm gonna be dead.
The only reason why I'm this toxic is because I'm playing a MOBA and I've never played a MOBA before until now.
You're like venom.
It's like spreading.
It's injected into my veins right now.
The MOBA toxicity.
I hear right after the 10 hour mark is where it really kicks in.
How come you guys aren't toxic?
Wait, they keep changing it to auto-select region and it's making me nervous.
You just haven't seen SageM late at night.
Yeah, you haven't seen me in solo queue.
You know the best part?
Late at night, I was like, bro, my team will not group.
And Danny Shifter was like, oh man, the MOBA's getting you, bro.
You gotta just chill.
And then I came in the next day and he was flaming the shit out of his team.
Wait, somebody is changing you.
You can change it yourself.
Somebody else is changing.
So who's changing it?
What, the region?
Yeah.
I'm changing it back.
We're battling, literally battling.
The first battle.
I'm changing it back.
I picked Warden specifically for the high ping.
I don't have to aim my ult.
Wait, let me turn on cheats real quick.
Who keeps, oh my god, dead cheats?
Enable.
F7, enable.
Now someone's gone?
You just kicked that guy right out of the game.
This cheat's enabled and they're like, I'm not dealing with this.
What kind of charity event is this?
That's it, let's forfeit.
If there's one thing kids love, it's cheating.
What does cheat's enable do anyway?
What kind of cheats does it give you?
Infinite money.
Walk through walls.
Hide anywhere.
Suddenly put bots in and then kick a person out.
What does it keep saying?
What are we waiting for anyway?
I don't know.
Doki?
Do some...
What do you want me to do?
Do something!
It could be the broadcast thing, right?
Yeah, I think they just got...
They just went back to...
Then they'll put it back to east, right?
You know, it could be like hurry up and wait.
No, I put it on east.
I don't know if it's the casters putting it on east or...
I think it might be the players.
Oh my gosh.
What's the word?
What's the word when you have a sign outside of a store but you're upset at the store?
Protesting!
Boycotting!
We're leaving.
Sorry, chat.
They should be back.
They said they're back now.
Krusty Krab is unfair.
Mr. Krabs is in there.
Standing at the concession.
Oh, they said they're gonna auto-server the server and see what it gives us, but like...
Someone click the drop-down US East at the last possible second.
Someone, but it's not gonna be us.
For the kids.
Yeah, for the children.
Someone does it, but like, it's definitely not gonna be us who does that.
Yeah, I hope it gets South Africa.
I'm VPNing right now.
Oh, look at that.
It's Goomy that doesn't pick at the end.
I'm VPNing to Antarctica, so that way it autos to South Africa.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see what ping we get.
I'm missing.
I'm nice.
Make sure you guys swap.
231 MS.
What do you guys get?
I have 134.
139.
You should've given us East.
Alright guys, I'm gonna roleplay.
I'm gonna roleplay.
Alright.
I'm swapping.
I jumped.
Oh my god.
We can complain now!
Are you guys lagging hard or are you guys okay?
I mean, it's 130 MS, of course.
It's definitely not East.
Is this South Africa?
I think it's South Africa.
I can't Kovacs this.
I got a shotgun, so just aim at the middle and we'll call it a day.
I can't Kovacs it.
They're denying it.
Yeah.
It's already over.
Lagging for the children.
100 ping!
Let's go!
I need a punch.
I don't have bullets for that gummy.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's the only way.
All I have to do is just hold down my button.
There you go.
I'm curious to see your hooks on this thing.
Yeah, I'm curious.
Yeah, I'm kind of curious too.
I couldn't see the orb because your big robot shoulder was in the way.
If I was on East, I'd be at 100 ping.
I could steal it.
I'm scared to get staked here.
Okay, I got staked.
They're playing really passive.
Oh, I needed the sleep dart.
What do you think you're doing, weirdo?
Vindicta characters for weenies.
100%.
Yeah, I feel like Vindicta is on the enemy team at least.
You know?
I agree.
It's okay, I'm not teleporting this time.
We're not getting any of our farm, but that's okay.
Yeah, we don't need creeps, right?
Yeah, we don't need it.
I'm pre-firing my laser.
Oh, that's not good.
You punched me into the...
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
That's pretty awkward.
Oh my god, guys, guys.
I co-vacced successfully.
I co-vacced it.
To be fair, I was...
Wait, they're diving you.
I was aiming for a minion, but the minion disappeared.
Disappeared!
Oh no, we should have told them to swap.
I was thinking about it.
Yeah, King, because we didn't say anything so they're like, they must be okay, right?
With coordination, this can be deadly.
We're the children, guys.
We're gonna lag.
Do it for them.
No, no, it's good.
It's good.
We might not make it today, too.
Oh, Fork, I forgot how small my hook was.
That is good.
Because one of our players has to survive a hurricane anyway.
Stop talking about it like that!
Yeowch!
I'm so scared of getting punched.
I wanna buy.
I'm buying.
Alright, alright.
Good comms.
Okay, I don't know what to do for my build here.
Okay, and then ult, and then one, two.
Okay.
How ahead of them are they?
I'll take the shot!
When she has ult, though, I can't stay.
How ahead of their farm are they from us?
Oh, they are.
They're pretty ahead.
Hey, listen.
Oh, he's in ult.
Oh, no.
I'm listening, I'm listening.
Nice.
Oh, yes, got it!
Okay, okay.
Wow, that hit me.
I fucking believed in you guys.
Wait, hook her into the tower.
Oh.
I put a bomb on her.
Nice, nice.
Did you do anything?
That was actually pretty good.
The bomb didn't go off.
Oh, okay.
That's okay, it's okay.
It's the thought that counts, you know?
It's the thought that counts.
It gave them a sense of...
Oh, shit.
The sense of...
They're scared now.
They're so scared.
Excuse me.
God, I feel so fucking weak like a little baby.
After playing Abrams, I don't know what I am anymore.
Oh, I'm so low.
I have ult.
Okay, nice.
Oh, she's on me.
Do me.
Boom!
Oh, even in the lag.
The lag undid my bomb?
Wait, what?
It does that?
We're gaming now, though.
We're gaming, we're gaming.
This feels worse than the first game for me.
I think gank blue.
Really?
Wait, you're in US East.
Yeah, I don't know.
That's crazy.
I had 180 ping, now I'm at 120.
I'm tethered!
That should not be possible.
Don't worry, CJ, I'll cast a bomb upon you.
Oh, thank you.
How much do you have, Ramblin?
111.
Yeah, so this is EU for sure.
Yeah, no, 100%.
I have 130.
I have 150.
Like, this cannot be East.
This could be East in our dreams.
If we close our eyes.
Wait, wait, wait.
This feels like nothing changed at all.
Okay, I'll farm now.
I had to look at my build and stuff.
I got confused.
Abrams is blue!
Oh, Abram is blue.
I'm here with you.
I look back.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm farming, I'm farming.
Please don't let me die.
I'll be honest, I was trying to hit the minion the entire time.
Is there healing in there?
I'm gonna go do my account.
I accidentally went downstairs and now I'm scared.
Now I have to go the long way home.
Is Talon in blue?
Yeah, I think Talon is in blue.
I need you back here.
I'm heading back, I'm heading back.
I'm heading back to you now.
I'm gonna go buy stuff.
I can't hook!
You can.
I believe in you.
I'm here.
On the map.
Oh my god!
Talon is back in purple.
Oh nice, nice.
I'll get on the side, I'll force him out.
He's one.
Oh!
Oh my god!
You slept the Wraith.
I backed up.
Wraith is kinda terrible.
Wraith is low, Wraith is so low.
He's fine, he's dead, he's dead, he's dead.
He's in the tower.
I'll go to purple.
I'm heading over.
I will play as safe as I can.
Oh, you're good, we have a lead.
We got this.
I believe.
Wait, actually...
Wait, what the fuck?
I got a Vindicta on me.
I'm gonna buy a fucking knockdown, you bitch.
If you do this again.
I swear to god, I will...
I will fucking buy a knockdown.
If you do that to me one more time.
Oh,
there's three, there's three.
Wait, three or two?
I'm in the area.
I'm gonna try to fight them.
I'm by myself right now.
They don't know I'm on the bridge.
Yeah, I'm by myself.
I'm going on Wraith.
I'm here with you.
Wraith is one.
Yeah, Wraith is so low.
I'm gonna grab the yellow.
Nice.
Oh, she fucked up her TP.
Oh.
Nice.
They bursted her left.
He's heading to you.
Whoever is over there.
Me and him are fighting.
Oh, he fucking left.
Oh.
Sorry.
Thanks for the farm, I guess.
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
I can't, I got tethered, I got tethered.
Yeah,
I'm fucking leaving.
I'm coming over to green.
You guys need help in green?
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll come back to blue.
They're coming to push blue tower.
Yeah, I'm back in blue now.
I'm here.
Goodbye, blue.
I'm here, blue.
I did not mean to hook you at all, CGM.
It's okay.
Life goes on.
It really does, doesn't it?
It's always fine.
No, it's like, it's all good.
There's a Wraith near me.
I'll try to look silly.
There's a Wraith here.
How am I gonna hook you when you look like that?
You can hold this.
I'll just get a buy and leave.
Is there someone there, purple?
There was Paradox, but she's gone.
Abrams is here on green.
Wait, there's...
Yeah, I'm coming over to blue.
I need help.
I have two on me.
I have two on blue.
Yeah, I'm pulling up.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Can you swap?
I slept, I slept, I slept, I slept!
I may be dead though from that, but...
Oh, I slept the Wraith.
Oh, we didn't get her.
Nice, nice, nice.
Talon's about to be there.
I'm dead to this, I think.
The ping.
Makes it so hard to ping.
One, two...
One, five...
Okay.
Alright, I just need...
Coming back.
Where should I go?
Yeah, we should shove in everything else, basically.
Okay.
Get that green tower.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I'm at green, I'm at green now.
I'm here, I'm here.
I'm here with you.
No one on the right side of the map.
Yeah, I can go shove in.
Can we get the green tower?
I'm over right now.
I can maybe push this walker.
Nice.
Get that buff as well.
Oh, right here.
I think it's killable.
She was not.
They have a lot of people.
Oh,
no.
No.
Eat hot chips.
I'm gonna grab this farm real fast.
Where are you, green?
Yeah, I see two in green.
They're heading to yellow.
Oh, yeah, they're heading to you.
My senses are honed.
I'm deaf.
It's about to get sticky.
I'm pretty low.
Where are they?
I see them.
They're right here.
I'm pretty bad.
I pushed the walker.
The walker's half.
He ran to this one.
Careful, I'm...
Oh, I...
I don't have the life steal for that yet.
Oh, no.
He's coming to me.
I can stall.
Yeah.
Nice.
He's half.
That was bad.
He's one.
Nice.
I think I got both of these walkers.
Yeah, I'm...
I'm not dipping.
There's a dynamo here.
I'm gonna try to defend this tower, but...
I'm a little low.
I'm dead as fuck.
This is a terrible ult by me.
I have a dynamo on me.
Teleporting.
Coming.
I have two.
I have two on me.
You have a lot on you.
Oh, more than two?
Oh, that's...
Oh, I...
I didn't realize.
Yeah, you have to back up fully.
I need heal.
This is the last one they need.
Oooo!
I'm alive!
I can be there in like 30 seconds with really good buy.
Okay.
Where should I go?
Should I go to...
I'm gonna be behind this Wraith.
I'm gonna go for Walker.
I have a Wraith on me.
I'm heading over to you.
Paradox is one.
Vindictus is on me also.
Oh, I got her.
I'm helping you.
Vindictus is low.
I'm on my way towards that fight.
I got lag-eated away.
I'm sorry.
Paradox here.
One HP of Paradox.
I'm heading over.
I have ult, so I can help.
Oh, nice.
They're doing it!
I'm just like that.
Coach is happy.
Oh, I slept the creep.
Huge, huge, huge.
That creep is really tired.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's EP now.
Oh, you guys scared the shit out of me there.
I'm gonna steal their shop too.
Oh, damn.
Steal their shop.
Yeah, that's very...
You said that earlier, and I was like, hmm.
You just mean shop at it?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm dipping.
I think I'm okay.
Oh, they're fucking heading over.
There's an Abrams to my left, by the way.
Oh, there's so many people over there.
I'm heading over to you.
I may be running.
Are we gonna fight?
There's a granny over there.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Oh, he fucking hooked me.
No!
Me too, me too.
Okay.
There's an Abrams right here.
As long as Ramblin survives all is well.
No.
Oh, I'm getting chased by Abrams.
He's on me, Abrams.
Alright.
I have to go back.
I'll never die.
I need to go back.
I'm solo.
I'm like fucking gonna die.
Okay, I'm gonna save for Ricochet.
Woah.
This is it.
It's Ricochet time.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, three green.
I'm heading over.
We have Blast and Bebop.
I haven't hit a single hook.
They're going for the tower.
Woah.
I'm here.
I'll be late.
He's late.
He's one.
Go, Bebop.
Go.
Are you mid?
Yeah, that's true.
They don't have a shop anymore.
It's stolen.
I'm here.
I have to be in the fucking pit.
Who's parrying?
I can parry.
Don't worry.
Alright, parry gang.
Parrying.
We got it.
Okay, I was gonna say, did we get it?
I think I killed somebody.
Nice.
Yellow lane needs help.
I'm heading over.
Oh.
You're gaming.
Oh, I might be dead.
It's okay though.
We can get the Paradox.
Did we get him?
Nah, I fried him.
We can just take the tower.
Yeah.
Yippee!
Oh shit.
I'm gonna get for the other tower.
Both your towers, I guess.
Goodbye.
I can go get purple.
Alright.
I'm gonna go farm.
I'll see you guys later.
I'll come back.
I'll get the urn.
Hey, I wanted to farm this.
We can farm together.
Come down here.
Yeah.
Come here.
There you go.
Hello.
Is that Talon near me?
Oh, I have a Wraith too.
I have somebody else.
Oh my god, they love me.
You just wanna be sure you're included, you know?
I'm saying, thank you, enemy team.
Paradox, it's Paradox for me.
Where'd he go?
Oh, I'm solo Blackhold.
It's vibes though, honestly.
You guys be okay?
I'm Q-Bert.
Oh, nice.
Q-Bert mode?
Paradox is my hero.
Oh my god, I'm so close to a Ricochet.
Please live for like 5 seconds.
Oh my god, I got it.
I'm gonna use the boost.
That's how desperate I want the Ricochet.
Where is this guy?
Okay, I'm heading over.
I worked hard for that Ramblin'.
I'm speeding!
Wait, where did he go?
He's so low.
Oh, that guy bamboozled.
He got a DPR.
Nice.
Off we go.
My team is just decoded.
We didn't need the NA ping, guys.
We didn't need it.
We're just gamers.
No wonder these guys are in loser bracket with us.
And I mean it.
He's asleep.
Abrams low.
What happened?
Alright, here we go.
Am I fucking dead?
Oh shit.
Who shot?
Oh, it's the grandpa.
I was not paying attention.
I was like, hee hee.
I believe in you guys.
I don't even need to be in the endgame.
I don't even need to be there.
Yay!
Alright, so anyway, guys.
We're going to be at day two.
That's not who I am as a person.
I let my anger take over me.
Guys, we're going to be in day two, guys.
Unlucky.
Can we let this team advance instead?
We should have FFed.
I think my game just crashed.
Suffering from success.
Is it 12pm tomorrow?
No, it's 6 in the morning.
No, no, no, I'm not doing it.
All I'm saying is, thank god my power's out because of the surge.
I think my power's going to be out too.
I will not be there.
Good luck at Doki and Juni at 6am.
No, I'm not there.
Guys, you guys, I should have told you guys.
I didn't think we would make it to day two.
You know, you got that at 6am.
Just tell them to advance the other team, man.
We did it for the kids.
I will donate to the charity if the other team gets advanced.
How much though?
Okay, how much?
Enough.
For the kids.
I'm waiting, I'm refreshing.
I'm refreshing the charity.
We'll let the other team play, but they have to be under Team Doki Bird.
Yeah, yeah, they can play as Doki Bird.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to be under Team Doki Bird.
No, guys.
No.
Okay.
I don't want to be the messenger though.
Congrats on making it to day two.
Wait, okay.
They said they will avoid having a start at 6.
Don't say like 6.30.
7.
You guys will be the 7am match.
Waking up at 6.30 to play on 180 ping.
Okay, how about we negotiate?
And like...
If you give us NA servers, we'll be fine.
I don't want to wake up.
We made it this far.
Can't we just advance another team?
What?
We can just advance another team, right?
Yeah.
What?
They're typing.
I don't know what they're trying to say.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe we made it.
You didn't believe in us?
That's because the silence was so loud.
That was the loudest silence I've ever heard in my life.
That is insane.
We're so good at video games, guys.
We're so good at video games.
Okay, who is the best at PR?
I need you guys to type a response for me and I'll copy it.
Type a PR message for me.
This guy is literally the face of Chipotle.
He is.
I want a bowl with white rice and black beans and chicken.
Why didn't you just say hey?
We really appreciate it.
You know, we love charity.
Bye!
Our team's not available.
We just filled in last minute, but we would love to send another team in our place and donate to Charity Smile.
Good luck to my boy Raiden portioning in the rain.
Wait, that's what I was saying.
I had to write something.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
No one can freak it like him in the rain.
Put that in there.
That's true.
I noticed you're drinking a Philz coffee.
Which order?
This is a black filtered soul cold brew.
A black coffee?
When you're an adult, you'll understand.
I drink black coffee.
But I drink black iced coffee.
I also drink black coffee, except decaf.
At home.
Decaf?
Are you an alien?
A reptile?
Wait, cold decaf?
I get really upset.
It makes me want to cry.
And I also vibrate.
That sounds like a dad.
That's how I am every day.
Oh.
Whoa.
It's like the Satsui no Hado.
Okay.
My chat gets that reference.
None of you will get that reference.
That's okay.
That was for my chat.
What would you guys understand?
It's like Sasuke suppressing his curse mark.
Oh, okay.
I don't watch anime.
Can you get me something more normie?
It's like when somebody wants to say that Raditz is going to die in a hurricane, but instead they say, like, I hope Raditz does well in the hurricane.
Oh.
Now you're speaking my language.
Right there.
Uh...
Yeah.
Okay, I'm leaving.
Are you still typing a message?
I already typed the first message!
Okay.
Alright, I said...
Okay, I'm still typing.
She's really locked in.
She's locked in.
Okay, I said...
One of them is literally in Hurricane Milton right now, so he won't have power tomorrow.
He just put it all on red!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have to feed my cats.
Did you mention that?
I also have to feed Seijin's cats.
Yeah, me and Ram got to feed my cats.
That's three down.
Yeah, yeah, I said half the team might not be able to make it because it's really early and one of them is literally in Hurricane Milton.
There's three cats, so I could use one more volunteer.
Oh, I am down.
I'm local.
Okay, so me, Void, and Ramlin got to feed my cats.
Now we're down to two.
I got to feed the past you.
Now it's just Doki.
Yeah, so...
And I'm West Coast, and that's...
Yeah.
I'm...
I can't...
All of us except Ray are West Coast, I think.
No, don't say that.
If it's Doki against the enemy team, that's just unfair, you know?
Like, Doki's just too good.
I mean, maybe they should just forfeit the rest of the tournament and we win.
Yeah, and then just Doki wins.
For the kids.
I think that sounds good.
Okay, they're typing.
They're trying to...
They're trying to negotiate with us.
Yeah, you got that, Doki.
They said, what about 915 PST?
They're negotiating.
I mean, that's the hurricane.
That's the...
We're having a negotiation session.
So...
915 is off the table for us.
Is that right?
I need us to be in advance so we have evidence.
I need...
That's why I'm vocalizing.
We forgot to ask Milton.
We gotta ask Milton.
Can you, like, come by later?
Can you, like, get me a car?
I got a deadlock, Kearney.
Can you, like, chow for a couple hours?
Milton doesn't care about your schedule.
Milton?
What do you think, Milton?
I'm not getting back.
Who's naming these, by the way?
I think Milton's ghosting us.
I don't think I like the name Milton.
There's, like, a groundhog that comes up and names the hurricanes.
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
I said, talked with the team, and we think we can't do it.
Is it possible to...
Is it possible to advance the other team?
Put it at 12 p.m.
or advance another team?
Hard negotiation.
Do you think this would be 12 p.m.?
Or the other group?
I think so.
Yeah.
Maybe 9 p.m.?
I don't know if it was super duper early, but...
They at least had, like, a couple-hour buffer before us.
Yeah.
Okay.
I said, talked to this team, and we think we can't do it.
As the best time will be at 12 p.m.
for us.
12 p.m.
Is it possible to advance the other team?
I'm sorry.
Let's tag in Milton.
Thoughts?
Team Milton.
Team Milton, join in the tourney.
Join the tourney.
For the kids.
Since half the team will be missing...
Half the team will be missing.
Okay.
If it turns out there's a Day 3 to this tournament, I'm gonna scream.
You said you can't even do Day 2!
And you're not even gonna be involved!
We didn't even know there was a Day 2.
Now there's about to be a Day 4.
It's a week-long event.
It's like the Dota International.
That was my bad.
I didn't think we would make it to Day 2.
Not gonna lie.
Why would you do that?
No, I told you, Gumi.
I told you there's a Day 2.
Yes, I did.
I remember.
I told you there was a Day 2.
And I was like, there's no way we're gonna make it to Day 2, right, Gumi?
And you were just like, yeah, nah.
And then I was like, okay, get a team.
I literally told you there was a Day 2!
Where?
In the car!
I don't remember.
You cannot pull that on me.
I literally told you there was a Day 2 in the car.
When I was like, do you want to do it?
Huh?
You say something?
You fucking whore.
You just had no faith in us this whole time.
That's so crazy.
It's not that I didn't have faith in you guys.
I just thought we would get eliminated earlier.
You had faith in the other teams.
Yeah, I did.
I honestly had faith that they would be better.
What if we're just the best?
You know, if we weren't on EU ping, who knows?
They used to use a system of...
How to name a hurricane.
I honestly thought we were gonna be facing against the teams with the pro players.
So that's why I was like, well...
If we're facing the teams with the pro players...
Maybe that'd be...
No faith.
That team would have been free if it was a West Coast server.
That's all I'm saying.
That's true.
But then we would absolutely be on Day 2.
Yeah, really?
My chat's saying it's our fault for not...
We let you down by playing so well.
That's true.
It's on us, really.
I'm literally on your team.
How could you guys not stand back harder?
Alright.
I gotta head off to my next stream now.
I'll see you guys.
GG's.
GG's, everyone.
Good job, everybody.
Bye-bye.
See you guys later tonight for scrims.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.
Okay.
I'm sorry I couldn't do Day 2.
Honestly, I was trying to negotiate.
Trying to see if we could get a middle point.
But, yeah.
The majority of the team can't do it.
Like...
There's nothing I can do.
I don't want to...
Yeah.
But it was fun.
It was really fun playing everybody.
Oh, my OBS crashed.
Whoops.
OBS crashed.
Oops.
Alright.
Sorry, my OBS crashed.
But...
Anyway, we're back.
I do feel really bad because it is a charity.
I even moved around my schedule to play until the very end.
And now we're late to the other collab.
Oh my gosh, my schedule is so all over the place.
But I had fun playing with the group.
I had fun playing with the group.
I was very surprised.
Like I said.
I really lost my train of thought.
But I tried.
I tried to see if I could get a middle point.
But since it's an EU tournament our team is full NA.
So there's nothing we can do.
Our team is like full NA.
I can try and find...
Okay, I don't know.
At this point, I don't want to force people to play if they don't want to play as well.
I don't want to force people to play if they can't play too.
It is what it is.
Anyway, I'm going to raid the next collab.
And then we're going to start the stream there.
It was fun.
No, I do not think they want to play against in the semi-finals.
No, I don't.
I heard about what happened in Group A.
I do not think they want to play against those teams.
I don't think they want to go again.
I don't know.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to raid into what happened.
Group A was the group with all the pros.
There were two teams that were full-on pro players.
Our team had fighting game pros, but the other one was actual FPS pros and MOBA pros and CS pros.
That's where Holostars were placed.
I don't think they want to go again.
That surprised Group B was the easier group.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to go raid to the other stream and then join them.
I'll see you guys there.
Thanks for coming.
I had a really fun playing with this team.
Sorry that we couldn't make it to date.
Sorry we couldn't play day 2.
If my team was okay with it, I would have played day 2, but if majority of my team can't do it, then my hands are tied at that point.
Anyway, I'm going to raid.
I'll see you guys there.
Bye!